hey everyone it's sarah with registered
nurse RN comm and today i want to go
over with you how to take a blood
pressure manually in the hospital
settings we're blessed because we have
automatic blood pressure monitors that
take our blood pressures constantly for
our patients but there are times in the
settings where we'll have to take them
manually especially if we don't trust
the monitor or you can't sometimes the
monitor won't read a patient's blood
pressure because their blood pressures
too low
so you have to know how to take a blood
pressure manually so in this video I'm
going to go over how to take a blood
pressure manually I'm actually going to
perform the skill and you'll get to
watch me do it and see how I do it and I
want to give you some quick tips that
I've just learned over the years with
taking blood pressures manually so first
let's go over equipment okay this is a
manual blood pressure cuff you can get
these anywhere Walmart off the internet
anything typically you have it comes
with a cuff it comes and make sure
because sometimes people buy these and
they don't come with this big mama tur
spigot mol manometer and always make
sure that whenever you're buying it says
with this big moment ometer because
sometimes you'll just get the cuff and
the the rubber bulb but you won't get
that and you'd have to buy that extra
this is the big thing of it so make sure
that it comes with this and you have
your rubber bulb that blows up with an
open and closed valve and a lot of times
they come with little neat carrying bag
so if you're a home health nurse you
have to travel a lot or you're just
wanting to take your own blood pressure
it's real neat to have your own cup um
also you need a stethoscope many times
if you're just learning to take your own
blood pressure that's why you're
watching this video this Cup actually
came with the stethoscope
but I like my own set the scope but a
lot of times they come with a set scope
so you'll need your cuff your big Amal
manometer and a but M sub scope so let's
go over exactly the steps of how to take
a blood pressure and then we will talk
then you'll actually see me perform the
skill okay whenever you're taking a
blood pressure in the clinical setting
anywhere you want to have the patient
set down have them be calm for about
three to five minutes if they're anxious
the real nervous or
crying or something like that have them
set sail for three to five minutes
setting in a chair with their legs
uncross and their arm at heart level
then what you will do you'll get your
cuff and you need to make sure that you
have the right size cup if you have too
large of a cup or too small of a cup you
will get an inaccurate reading which is
not good so whenever you put your cuff
on the patient take a look at the
patient's arm and you can tell if the
patient is really little in this area
you probably need a smaller adult or if
they have a larger arm you might need a
large cup how you tell is that you put
the cuff on the arm which I'll show you
with my patient that we'll be doing here
in a second and you stick two fingers
underneath the cuff and if they fit just
right you have the right sized cup if
not if it's too tight to loose you need
to get another size cuff next you're
going to ask your patient what arm you
can take their blood pressure in some
people have preferences and make sure
the patient has not had an AV shunt
placed in their arm or they have an IV
in their arm or a PICC line they've had
a mastectomy or history of blood loss
anything never want to take a blood
pressure in that type of arm so put your
cup on the patient you're going to feel
for the brachial artery and I want you
to pack this this with me your brachial
artery is found on your elbow and it's
the distal part closest to your body and
the best thing is to extend your arm out
as much as you can and feel that
bounding and I can feel mine right now
and that is your brachial artery that is
the artery that we're going to be
feeling and listening for so you'll put
your cuff on the patient and on your
cuff you will notice these little arrows
and you'll have an arrow down that'll
say left arm you have an arrow down that
says right arm so if you're using the
left arm you're going to make sure that
that arrow is literally right on or
slightly above that brachial artery so
you'll put that on there and then you'll
take your set the scope and your
stethoscope has two sides to it it has a
diaphragm and a bail studies have shown
that it's really personal preference on
what side you want to listen to I like
to listen with my diaphragm so you're
going to take your sub scope put it put
it in your ears and you're
to take the Steyr frame and you're going
to put it over that brachial artery then
you are going and when you hear it
you're going to inflate the cuff with
the rubber bulb and typically you
inflate until you cannot hear the
brachial artery anymore
this is generally on your little spigot
momen ometer you will inflate all the
way up to 180 to 200 to 200 millimeters
of mercury 180 is usually sufficient
enough another how you can know how much
to inflate is ask the patient what their
top number which is their systolic
normally runs and if they say it runs a
hundred you would inflate to 130 240
millimeters of mercury so the rule is
usually to inflate 30 to 40 millimeter
millimeters of mercury more than what
they say that their blood pressure is
but I like to stick with 180 so you
inflate there once you inflate you start
you take your rubber bow and you start
letting out air slowly very slowly if
you do it too fast you'll get an
inaccurate reading you do it slow where
you're seeing that needle drop down two
to three millimeters of mercury and let
me show you what I'm talking about
behind me I have I've drawn it's not the
best drawing but I've drawn a little
speaking spin Amal manometer that you
would see and your needle typically
starts right here at the end and as you
inflate it goes up so where you would
all want already inflate to the 180 mark
then when you're letting out the air to
a hundred and two to three millimeters
of mercury you're going to do it slowly
so it'll do something like this you'll
see this little needle and it'll just
start going slowly and then all of a
sudden you'll hear both okay so we'll
pretend we heard the boof at the 120
mark so we're systolic is 120 then
you'll keep hearing the noise you'll
keep hearing boo boo boo boo boo boo boo
boo boo boo boo boo boo boo and then all
of a sudden it'll stop and you make know
where it stopped that and we'll say it
stopped right here which is the 70 mark
and that is our diastolic so the
patient's blood pressure is
120 over 70 then after you get that what
you're going to do is you're going to
open the valve all the way let all that
air come out and tell the patient what
their blood pressure is always tell the
patient what their blood pressure is a
lot of patients want to know and some
people may not ask you because I feel
like it might be rude to ask so just let
them know and explain what that reading
means a lot of people's like well as I
higher is that love and explain to them
what that is a normal blood pressure
reading is usually 120 over 80
but we're not we're not all perfect and
we all can't have that great blood
pressure typically the golden rule you
want that top number to be at least 100
and if the top which is on a little bit
of a lower side but if that top number
starts going the 150s 160s 180s high
that's not good that's hypertension
you'll need to let the doctor know now
that's how you take a blood pressure so
let's go over some quick tips and then
we'll do our skill you want to use that
correct size remember the two finger
rule fit it underneath the cuff make
sure it doesn't fit too snug too tight
just right and if the patient has smoked
so always ask them if they've smoked if
they ate or they just got done
exercising it's best to wait about
thirty minutes before you take that
blood pressure because you can get an
inaccurate reading and again no blood
pressures in patients whose hat who've
had a V Shutts mastectomies blood clots
anything like that
so now let's do our skill of recording
or getting a blood pressure here we have
our patient it is my awesome husband Ben
and he is here to be my test dummy for
doing our blood pressures so the very
first thing you want to do is you want
to have your patient sat down and if
they've been running around or really
anxious or talking you want them to be
calm for at least three to five minutes
before you take their blood pressure
because you want to get the most
accurate response then you will have
them have their legs uncrossed and have
their arms down by their side and you
want to ask them what arm you can take
their blood pressure in because a lot of
patients are have preferences on what
blood what arm you can use especially if
they've had an AV shunt or a blood clot
in the arm or mastectomy you would never
want to take a blood pressure in that
arm
so I'm going to use bins left arm you
want to get your manual blood pressure
cuff and your stethoscope and what we're
going to do is we're going to put on our
left arm and on your blood pressure cuff
you have little arrows that say left and
right these arrows are meant to go over
the brachial artery so we're going to
slider cuff up through the brachial
artery and I'm going to just feel on his
brachial artery where his artery is and
it's always on the inside of the elbow
and always have them Bend that arm up
really good because it pushes the pulse
up and he has a really nice one right
there so what I want to do is I'm going
to take where it says that left arm
arrow and I'm going to put it right
about two inches above that artery
that's where you want the cuff to rest
above the elbow about one and a half to
two inches and you always want to make
sure that your cuff fits the patient you
have really small patients and then you
have some obese patients who would need
larger or smaller cups and to check your
cuff size use two of your fingers and
just slide it underneath the cup make
sure it fits good not too snug not too
loose because if you have a blood
pressure cuff that does not fit you will
get an inaccurate reading and this cuff
fits him great so we have that now what
we're going to do so we're going to get
our Spig monitor and we're going to just
clip it here you can do whatever you
want with it as long as you can see it
because this is going to tell us
everything that we need to know for his
blood pressure now what I want to do
with my stethoscope is I'm just going to
listen at that artery and a lot of
people and it really doesn't matter you
can listen with the diaphragm or the
Bell of your stethoscope studies have
shown it does not matter I like to use
my diaphragm so I'm going to place it
over his brachial artery
let me fill it again fill it right there
and now I'm going to close the valve on
the blood pressure cuff and I'm going to
pump it up you pump it up at least 30 to
40 millimeters of mercury of what they
say that their blood pressure is
a lot of patients don't know what their
blood pressure normally runs so it's
always safe to say to blow the cuff up
to 180 to 200 millimeters of mercury
that's usually sufficient enough in a
patient so what we're going to do is
we're going to inflate our cuff to that
amount or until we do not hear the
brachial artery anymore like I said
we're going to inflate to about 120
I mean 180 millimeters of mercury then
we're there and I'm going to slowly
release open my valve where it goes down
at least two to three millimeters of
mercury
just slowly and what I'm doing is I'm
listening for that first beat that first
beat will be our top number which will
be our systolic and I'll tell you when
I've heard it we're passing 130 passing
120 and I just heard it just now at the
110 mark I'm still hearing it still
hearing it and notice how it's ticking
see a little moving up and down okay and
then it has stalled it's stopped at 62
so 110 over 62 is his blood pressure and
I've slowly let the air out flood
pressure was 110 over 62 and always tell
the patient what their blood pressure is
because a lot of people like to know I
know I've been in hospital settings and
no one told me what my blood pressure
was and I would have loved to know and
then of course take the cuff off of them
and if you have to repeat the blood
pressure you can do it in about five
minutes and it's good to switch arms
so thank you so much Ben for being my
test dummy and that's how you take a
blood pressure okay I hope I helped you
learn how to take a blood pressure
manually thank you so much for watching
and be sure to check out my other
nursing clinical skill videos we have a
lot of those in also teaching series and
be sure to visit my website registered
nurse Orion comm for all your nursing
student needs and be sure to subscribe
to this channel thank you so much for
watching